[Music]
over these past months of coronavirus
i like many others have been fixated on
the news
and if you live in the united states
last year we went through a presidential
election and many of us were obsessed
with the news but there's this one
nagging question this thing that
gnawed at me which is can i trust the
news
i call james harding he's the founder
and editor-in-chief
of tortoise a new news organization and
the former head of the news for the bbc
to sit down and talk to me about what
the news could be
about what the future of news must be
this
is a bit of optimism
james i can't tell you what a treat it
is to see you it's been a while
yeah since i've sat down and talked to
you yeah and it's been a while since
we've seen
any other humans it's been a while since
we've seen in other humans that too yeah
yeah i think we've learned a lot during
covid a lot has been revealed to us the
importance of space the importance of
gratitude and valuing you know our
relationships
but the other thing that has confounded
me over kovid
is who and what to believe and
i try and get my news from multiple
sources and i try and get my news from
sources that are on opposite sides of
the political spectrum because i'm
always curious how
things are being reported from both
sides
and then i try and sort of make my own
determination as to what
reality is but the question i have for
you as a career
journalist or career newsman where do i
get the truth
i mean i've just gone through an
election yes here in the united states
and much has been made of fake news
which is
now in our vernacular in the extreme
influence of social media where now
anyone can post anything
and it's held at the same standard as as
journalism
and so with such a massive influx of
misinformation disinformation
manipulation
i'm finding it harder to know where to
get the truth
and who to believe and our instinct is
to believe the people who
sort of reflect our own political
beliefs because you know it reinforces
our own
biases but that doesn't make it the
truth that just makes it nicer to hear
let me try a theory on you i think
2020 may mark
a move to post-politics news
right by which i mean the biggest story
of the year coronavirus has not been
much helped
by looking through a republican or
democrat lends
a conservative or liberal lens in fact
you really want to understand things
in ways that are a data driven
b with a time scale of science
c really interestingly we've been in a
decade
where the political argument has been
about the nation
i think the thing about the pandemic
that's really interesting is that
nationalism whichever
approach you take to it has been really
unhelpful
in the corona virus which is something
that operates globally
and is experienced locally and so that's
the other
thing is that there's been like you said
right at the top some about place
right place is a big thing right it's
been really really evident
that we think differently about the
planet but we also think differently
about where we are where we live and
work
and so i wonder whether or not we'll
come away thinking
yes i really do care about the news but
i care about the news
as regards the place i mean as regards
the
data that i get access to and the
quality of that data
as regards news not in the moment not
events based news but news
over time and so i think that that might
give us ways of looking at what's
happening in the world that's different
from left right
but the thing that i think is so
different now about news now than where
it used to be and i think
how social media has been able to
penetrate standard news you know
legitimate news
is that in the past the news was a
trusted source where i could just turn
on the television or open the newspaper
and i could basically trust even if
there was some political bias i could
basically trust that the reporting i was
being given
i could believe now i can't simply open
a newspaper or turn on a television
station but rather
you what you're saying to me is i have
to go on my own search as an individual
to find what i believe to be the truth
yeah i don't buy that to be honest with
you
not the not the last bit i think that's
true i think that you have to be
a consumer of news in a way in which you
are going to have to be a consumer of
streaming tv you know it takes a while
to find the things that are really worth
watching and we're gonna have to learn
how to navigate
you know the guide the thing i don't
agree with is that it was
much better years and years ago okay
this idea that there was this
kind of delphic source of news you know
you could tune into it
and it would tell you what was really
going on and what was going to happen
next yeah
it wasn't like that i think there's a
thing that we really underestimate
is the extent to which there was
enormous information inequality
right i don't think it's nearly fixed
yeah but it's much more fixable than it
was what does that mean what does
information inequality mean information
quality means that
if you were wealthy and college educated
you had access to much much better
sources of information
than the vast majority of other people
if you lived in certain in the united
states certain metropolitan centers you
had
way better sources of information
nationally and internationally
what i think is happening in the news is
not about
left and right left and right is the
thing that enrages people
what's happening is about places of
darkness
right by which i mean there are places
where geographically
there's just no provisional news you're
not finding out what's happening in the
courts you're not finding out what's
happening
you know in the state legislature and
the governor's mansion
you're just not finding it out at all
you're not getting that community
information
and then the other thing is there are
parts of our lives
right and until the coronavirus
science and medicine and healthcare were
one of those parts of our lives where
we got really really odd you know
occasional
versions of the news that's my point
about post politics news
is can we stop thinking about the news
in terms of crossfire or you know new
york times versus wall street journal
cnn versus fox
because these these arguments right
the sort of you know what was bill
o'reilly versus
you know what is racial matter those
arguments weirdly make us feel good
because they affirm
things that we feel they don't help us
to discover things
that we need to know but i want to go
back to something you said how it's
become our response
and i hear you and that again puts the
responsibility on the consumer
to go as you said you know like a movie
that we want to watch on tv we have to
sort of we sit there and watch all the
trailers and trying to decide what
to watch that that's how news has become
but the problem is
is the algorithm that that is google
attempts to
show you the thing it thinks you want to
see
not necessarily the thing you're asking
for and so a study i was told about uh
not that long ago
was that people with left-leaning
politics who said i
i'm trying to find the truth i reject
you know the the political
biases of of the traditional news
sources that are available to me
i'm gonna do my own research and i'm
going to go into google and i type in
benghazi to find out what's really going
on
and if you have lift-leaning politics
google shows you left-leaning
news items if you have right-leaning
politics google shows you right-leaning
news so you get completely different
answers
and the study showed is that if you're
completely independent and have no
political leanings
google shows you travel advice yes
and so even well-intentioned citizens
who are attempting to use
a search engine to find news cannot find
news
that doesn't play to their biases no no
we've got a massive problem here
which is people who are responsible for
the provision of information
in society in which information is
the most important tool in decision
making
right have gone from saying they're just
providing a platform and let everything
you know let the chips fall where they
may to acknowledging that their business
model
actually has impact on the outcomes and
information
so now saying in a way that i find
really hard to swallow oh you know what
we're now seeking regulation but let's
face it this is a systemic
failure of the public square right that
is just what's happened yeah you know i
grew up
in newspapers in the uk we had a very
clear understanding
of our responsibility we could be
curious we could lean into your life as
long as it was in the public interest
and the nature of the law that
underpinned the special privileges and
properties of a journalist
were that you could do so in the public
interest i
it was necessary for the citizens to
know i moved out of newspapers into tv
and radio
and there we had a system which was
known as public service broadcasting the
bbc
and the bbc again you were able to
not only be curious about people's lives
but frankly put it on tv
again as long as it met certain
understandings of what was in the public
interest
public service right with digital
there's been nothing at all
and i've been arguing for well quite a
few years now
you need to have something that's the
equivalent so i think
the public standard for digital
information
and then it's incumbent on the owners of
those platforms
google and facebook and all the rest of
it to say we provide information
that meets a public standard that's not
inimical to free speech
right that's essential to the
functioning of a public square okay i
think what you're saying is very
interesting i think the newspaper
industry
in particular did this to themselves yes
they devalued themselves
yeah which is to your point you know
journalists go to school there's
standards inside newspapers you you
separate the editorial staff from the
publishing staff
and there's this thing that we herald
called journalistic integrity
right that has certain standards and
when the internet showed up
and i remember this when bloggers
started blogging which is basically
anyone with an email account could now
be a newsman right
the newspapers they got so freaked out
by the internet that instead of
doubling down on journalistic integrity
and separating themselves from the
blogosphere and saying yes
those are bloggers and we are newspapers
they devalued themselves and told
all of their journalists to start
blogging yeah and in so doing
raised the credibility of the
blogosphere they allowed for
a blogger to have equal ranking equal
standing in our society
as a trained journalist with a degree in
how to do this thing called journalism
and now we're suffering the side effects
where
the blogger and the journalist are no
longer distinguishable okay so
we have i don't think this podcast is
working i think because here's the
problem
i am supposed to be you know darkly
cynical
and you're supposed to be you know
optimistic
borderline pollyanna you know and and
now i'm gonna say to you that you're
wrong because you're much too
you know negative on this and here's the
other suddenly
so i think that something is really good
is happening a lot of the journalism
that you talk about
10 20 years ago as being this integrity
journalism
it wasn't we were just putting out like
three four five stories a day i mean i
remember when i started out as a
reporter at the ft
you know we'll be like oh yeah this
story's coming make two calls
report it tell there's a press release
here's another company results
i remember from the minus the wall
street journal saying look i'm not good
but i'm fast right and and that was
that was i mean and that was that was
appealing
it was a reasonable post what's
happening to us
is that we are all being forced to
identify
not just information that's new not just
information that i have that you don't
right but information that's really
valuable
insightful that tells you something that
you
need to know i'll give you an example in
our own year
right so you know when we first started
talking
which is nearly three years ago now
what we were talking about i was saying
i think i'm going to leave the bbc
i'm going to set up a slow newsroom part
of the idea was
it will be better by being slower right
by not chasing after headlines
and part of the thinking was it would be
different by being open
that we'd have our news meetings but
they'd be open right
what's happened i think this year is
that
firstly we've had an amazing year right
i know everyone's knackered or i can't
see straight
but the appetite for slow news the
appetite
for yes the latest data the latest
press conference has been huge but also
there's been a real growth in people
saying hang on
what's driving this what other forces
that are behind this
so a there's an appetite that's
impressive but for us in process
terms simon it's really changed we are
much much more focused on once we've
identified
the subject that matters then how do we
distill
that to find the story that tells you
the different elements of the issue
right so what we found has
really changed is that it's one thing to
say
hey why can't we plant a trillion trees
to deal with the
climate crisis hang on a second we can
do better than that we can find the
person
who counts trees and then we can tell
the story of
tom crowther who counts trees and the
battle over tree counting
that is itself a proxy for you know
which countries in the world
and where are we really dealing with
climate
and that is and for me what that says is
just your bigger point is
no no don't take the 10-year view that
every journalist became a blogger and
vice versa
actually journalists have been forced to
raise their game
because there's just so much more
information out there so this is very
interesting where there's an appetite
not just for the news
but for an explanation of how the news
came to be yeah
we want to understand the reason because
it is in the reason of how it came to be
that's more objective and i can now draw
my own conclusion
yeah and what you're suggesting is that
in this 24-hour news cycle news as a
business
when you make your revenue from
advertising yeah especially on
television
that's a problem because ratings become
the thing to drive but
what you're saying is is that simply
reporting what has happened yesterday or
this week
is insufficient i want to understand the
underlying meaning
root and people involved yeah
and and i don't have the time or
attention to go research that
so i'm looking for what you're saying is
the new raised standard of journalism
to go investigate that for me so i'll
give you a concrete example
which is we talked about how would you
tell a story
and create elements of the story that
gave people greater
access to your thinking right we started
i don't know why this was but with a
why right we started it
i like it i like it go on go on by the
way this is an idea you may want to pick
up
i can't believe i'm giving you all my
best stuff here but the idea was after
we've spoken outside oh yeah that's
quite interesting
imagine if at the top of your story you
have a box yeah every time you tell a
story which is
why the story yeah why this story
matters yeah so we introduced that
that was quite good actually in my world
that was massively innovative people
were
i love the fact that every time you do a
story you've got a box that says why
this story and that you as the editor
have explained why you've chosen to tell
the story the thing that was interesting
was
that was an innovation i think that what
you're talking about is
it's an old-fashioned industry that is
being disrupted in a very positive way
yeah and so what you're doing at
tortoise what's happening
at axios yeah these are career
news people that i think are disrupting
and offering alternatives
to what it were considered the standards
in journalism
yeah because i i like disruption you
know just like
when industries get old and stale they
deserve to be disrupted in journalism
surely it's being disrupted well
journalism by the way the truth is
journalism has been disrupted
not by other journalists we're just
responding to the fact that the old
models
don't work they don't work for consumers
in terms of information and they don't
work for
the commercial side either but kind of
give an example of where i think
culturally things have changed right and
and take people who kind of if you like
not in the same
swim as me right so whatever you think
about fox news
the really interesting thing that
happened in the course
of election night right was arizona
and the thing that people most liked of
course was you know jared calls rupert
rupa doesn't necessarily respond they
stick by the
call they've made on arizona but
culturally what had changed
was that they brought in the team of
psychologists that are on the desk
making the judgment and they show you
their workings
right they say look we've made this
judgment because what our read is that
there's a one in 400 charts
that trump picks up arizona right when i
started out as a reporter
everything was behind closed doors
editorial meetings behind closed doors
the
kind of invested team operated by and
closed doors but even the sharing of our
data
operated behind closed doors one of the
things that's happening with the
disruption
is that you are seeing much more of that
shared publicly
this is this conversation is not helping
me the i know
but the things about it was a
preposterous idea you've said let's have
a positive conversation about the news
right
i mean like let me just tell you the
jumble of thoughts that are going
through my head
that are sort of they're not depressing
me i'm just left
just as confused now as i started off at
the beginning so
the television news used to be a public
service and in the united states
you know a deal was made that the fcc
would allow
the tv stations to prosper and make
money off the public airwaves
in return for a public service called
the news
and it gave rise to people like walter
cronkite yeah
and it happened in 1979 during the
the iran hostage crisis that for the
first time ever
the ratings of the news went yeah
and ted koppel and the newshour all of a
sudden
had the potential to make money they
could no longer be a public service
and in the 80s there's this conversion
where the business people at the tv
stations just ignored the news and let
them do their thing and
so the integrity was the thing and then
all of a sudden it became a business and
unlike in the newspapers where you had
the separation of the business side
and the journalist side here you now had
the business
people getting involved in the news
dictating what things should be reported
and what things shouldn't be reported
and advertising became a thing so if it
bleeds it leads
because it drives eyeballs which drives
ad dollars
and the gross influence of money in
business
intertwined now we can't distinguish but
really in the 80s
gave rise to this this screwed up system
to the point where we now reach where if
i turn on
one of the apps from one of the tv
stations where they now report opinion
as if it's news
so they have a headline that's a
standard headline and then i i notice
what they do it's very sneaky
they'll put the name of the tv
personality
yeah not necessarily a journalist and
then
comma and then the headline that they
said their opinion
but it's reported as a headline you know
the news is biased and has no place in
the world harding
my point is is we are now at the point
because of business
that we are no longer presented forget
about distinguish
that we're no longer presented news as
news versus opinion it's all become a
blur
yeah so i think that
what you're talking about are systemic
failures
in the media in the way in which we were
talking about
systemic failures on the internet yeah
and when i say systemic the thing that's
important to me is
i was in a conversation earlier today
where someone said to me what's the
difference between responsible business
and responsible capitalism and my
responsible business
is operational right it's a company
saying
you know we're good on emissions
responsible capitalism is systemic
it's where you've introduced
expectations
around carbon taxes or emissions or
you know behaviors and what happened i
think
around the media and i think you'll make
it easy to demonize business
and you let journalists and journalism
off the hook
you know the journalists like the
attention too they like the success and
they like the prosperity
that came with it yeah so i'll give you
the uk version of it
really interesting right so we are torn
culturally
between two marketplaces for information
a fleet street the newspapers
and the bbc right fleet streets kind of
founding myth is john wilkes a man who
fought for freedom of speech and against
the licensing of newspapers
individuals would be free to say what
they wanted
and you know in the us i think the
closest echo is probably jefferson
right jefferson's argument you know that
a society
where there was freedom of expression
was safer than any other society in the
world
and he sort of championed the pamphlets
in that way
that was a kind of founding myth of
fleet street the founding
myth of the bbc was different in 1922
as people began to wrap their heads
around the possibility of broadcasting
and the idea of journalists reaching
into the minds of millions of people
the government of the uk got spooked
they thought to themselves good grief if
we allow journalists or even worse
proprietors right to have that kind of
power
that is terrifying so they created the
uk
a licensing regime in which anyone who
was getting a
receiver and anyone who had a
transmitter had to have a government
license
and with that license came certain
regulatory requirements
on standards of output and the bbc
model was we are going to provide the
best of everything to everyone so it had
a high public purpose
it had a high global purchase that the
kind of
motto of the bbc is nation shall speak
peace alternation
right but there is quite a detailed
regulatory regime
which is not just you're going to have
to deliver news in order to get that
access
it's quite clear what kinds of news and
the culture of the news that's required
and so you have these two competing
information marketplaces
fleet street free fall and regulated
bbc and that tension and it's often
quite an aggressive tension between the
two
i think is really important what's being
lost in the states
is that for a long time network news
was a very american echo of the bbc
right so it wasn't the bbc but it was an
alternative
and the metropolitan dailies had a
culture because of place
right there but what happened is cable
news
and then to my mind digital news drove a
coaching horses through both of those
that's such an interesting point which
is what makes a democracy work
is that we have multi-parties yeah we
don't have
oligarchy we don't have one party who
runs the show and it's the tension
that's supposed to keep
the society in balance yeah you know in
a business you'd say that it's the
tension of the visionary and the
operator yes
it's that beautiful tension that makes
something work at its best
and what you're saying is that in the
news media the thing that's been lost
is that we're quick to blame or demonize
but the reality is it's the loss of this
special tension
yeah and the reason it feels unbalanced
is because it very much is
unbalanced because there's no opposing
party
that has a different point of view about
how news should be delivered
and the irony is you know what he was
saying we did this to ourselves
right i think we did this to ourselves
ideologically
as well as commercially and by that i
mean that
people like me who spent their lives
you know really believing in jokes i
still do i really believe in the
importance of information in the news
also spent 30 years campaigning against
the propaganda machines
of you know eastern europe or the soviet
bloc as was or communist china
and even today we fight for freedom of
speech because there's never been in
some ways a worse time to be a
journalist given how many are being kind
of
suffocated or rubbed out and so when if
you like
the tech crew came along and said
are you for freedom of speech we were
like hell yeah that's absolutely what
we're for
right we don't want to have government
regulating what you say
because look what happens in you know
belarus or moscow
or beijing and the problem is in that
process
we've lost as you say it's not even a
balance it's a contest isn't it it's two
world views around information that both
must be operating at the same time yeah
you know one of the things i know about
your organization tortoise and what i
know about
axios is axios says if you want a job
here
you may not express any political
opinion
in your personal twitter feeds or social
media and you may not go to a protest
because we are journalists we stay
out of the fray and if you don't like
that standard
don't work here and what i like about
this is it's creating
a necessary tension which is what you
want which is you want the opposing side
which is what we consider the
traditional media now where we're
getting most of our news
to look at that and say you're crazy and
we want that little tension we want that
little battle to
happen because it's in that tension it's
in the different points of view of how
news should be delivered
that we're more likely to get a better
quality news i think that
the the thing i found myself saying
again and again and again this year's
it's revealed more than it's changed
right and
yeah yeah it's revealed
this generation gap it's revealed
obviously a global gap east versus west
i think it's revealed a real gap between
centers and regions this gap of place
but i also think that it's revealed an
ideological gap
right and it doesn't need to be and it's
not one that is the old left-right
politics
that takes me back to the post-politics
is a silly point to make because
the truth is politics will shift to
consume any argument
so the differences that we have now
around responsible information and trust
will be
championed by different sides in a
political argument because politics
moves to
you know a doctor or he's into an
argument
but i think there is something there i
love this i think the idea the need for
attention and that the news media has
lost the tension
yeah and it's old school news people
like yourself
who've come up through the system and
have now you're looking at the system
going no
no no there's a piece that's missing
yeah it doesn't mean i reject the system
i came up in
but there's a piece that's missing that
needs to be included in this system to
create balance
some can ask you a question though yeah
i
am really intrigued to know if you're
having these conversations with a bunch
of people
and you're inviting them in on the
grounds that this has been a tough year
but let's find you know a bit of
optimism frankly it's a very english
title isn't it sort of like let's not
oversell it
so but simon what are you honestly
feeling
has it been a year that has given you
grounds to be optimistic or do you think
you are
sifting for optimism when the trend
in what you're seeing and thinking is
the other direction
my answer is neither
uh or if i want to be optimistic it's
both
i have really been practicing always
seeking balance
and so when something bad happens
it's my instinct to say well hold on a
second
what good has come out of this also or
what's the positive side of this
and when something good happens it's my
habit to say well hold on let's not get
too carried away
you know i seek balance and so i have
two answers to your question one is
objective and one is subjective
the subjective one is we've all gone
through all kinds of emotions no one has
escaped the trauma
of covid and somebody asked me this
morning in fact
how have you been sleeping and the
answer was i've had some good weeks and
i've had some bad weeks yeah right
i've had weeks where i've slept
incredibly well and i've seen some weeks
where it's been really bad
and she said oh good if you said i've
been sleeping well all the time i would
have hung up and said
you're lying to me the point being is
the subjective part is
there are days that i've struggled to be
optimistic and there are days that
i'm only optimistic the objective side
is in all of this trauma and tragedy
that is around us
there is a lot of good that has happened
yeah
and i think it's important for us to to
find the balance
yeah i believe in those tensions and
those balances i think that's that's
important
the reason i ask because i've thought
about this a lot
i thought about a lot partly because i'm
a kind of positive person i've got a
sunny disposition
and also i think like a lot of people
i've been really touched by
the nature of patience and generosity
and love
right this year and i see all of that
and and also i'm alive to the criticism
that journalism just always hops on
about the negative and doesn't actually
can't tell
the human story that is soft and good i
get that right so that's the sort of
throat clearing the problem i've got is
one certainly in the uk if i were trying
to distill
my critique of the reasons why
we have had such a high excess death
rate
and the reasons why we are so hard hit
in terms of livelihoods and it's been so
much worse for some than for others
if i were to sum that up i would say
optimism bias
that time and time again the problem has
been that we've
hoped things would turn out better than
they did and then scramble to make the
difference
and so i didn't want to get to the end
of this conversation without just
flagging up
but i think that i think the optimism
itself
has had a bit of a kicking in 2020. i'm
going to push back here
i agree with the the premise
i think it's a positivity bias not an
optimism bias
what's the difference so in my mind
positivity
is what you're talking about
everything's fine it's fine
it's going to be fine we're fine it's
fine
right it's overblown we'll get through
this it's fine right
where optimism is not a denial of the
current state optimism is the belief
that the future is bright
but it accepts current darkness
so positivity would say everything's
fine go about your business
and we'll get through this just fine
you'll see and then there's the
scrambling to your point
optimism says this is a dark time we
have to hunker down
this is going to hurt but i know that
the future is bright
i can see the light at the end of the
tunnel i know if we come together and
work together
that we will come through this better
and stronger than we went in
well i think by the way i'm not sure
that you may not want to do a u-turn in
2021
and get into the pessimism business
because i think everyone's going to be
crowding into this optimism space
on pessimism it's a saturated market
and in the theme of tension and
maintaining tension of optimism getting
too much
too many headlines i think i better i
better uh go pessimistic to maintain the
attention and also it'd be good for the
brand simon it'll be good for you like
simon says
it'd be an actual story like simon says
i used to be such an optimist but i've
had a rethink
right exactly yeah exactly okay let me
see if i can sum this up let me see if i
can sum this up okay
which is just like nature abhors a
vacuum
so do people yeah we need attention we
need balance
we need yin and yang we need good and
evil you know
we need these tensions and in this news
journalism industry
that as it's matured and become a thing
it's become sort of a mush
and unfortunately because the way news
and journalism is delivered today is
largely the same regardless if it's
liberal
or conservative republican or democrat
it's kind of the same mush
the tension that has been exaggerated
because human beings need
that opposition because it's not come
from the news media itself it's become
very political so the tension has become
left
and right and that's the tension in the
news but the reality is
the tension that's actually needed the
healthier tension
is an entirely new way to deliver news
and the tension has to be between the
traditional news media
regardless of their political bias and
new sources of news
that are challenging the the system
that's what we need
yeah by the way not only do i like that
i've even got a headline for you which
is a tension
deficit very good do you like that very
good
it's all together it's packaged a
tension deficit yeah simon thank you for
inviting me on it's really really nice
to chat with you i don't think there's
ever been a time where i've talked to
you where i haven't learned something or
walked away a little wiser
and this is no exception and likewise
we'll take good care of yourself
you too
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you